es ist eine der größten entdeckungen der
raumfahrtgeschichte flüssiges wasser auf
dem mars gibt es jetzt die möglichkeit
von leben auf dem roten planeten
alle infos dazu jetzt hier bei pixum
science fiction forscher des georgia
institute of technology in atlanta ist
wohl einer der größten entdeckung
überhaupt gelungen auf einer
pressekonferenz der nasa haben sie erste
beweise für flüssiges wasser auf dem
mars vorgestellt das ist der erste
planet außer der erde für ein leben das
gelungen ist die nasa raumsonde mars
reconnaissance orbiter
kurz mmo hat spuren von salz süd raten
gefunden ein spektrometer genauer gesagt
das kompakt re con sens inmagine
spectrometer zeichnete infrarot wellen
im bereich von 10 mikrometern auf diese
wellenlänge ist typisch für salz hydrate
wie beispielsweise machen magnesium
perchlorat zitat die messung ist
sensationell es ist sehr schwer diese
salze zu messen so ralf jaumann vom
deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr im wort salze traten
versteckt sich die sensation hydro ist
gleich wasser hydrate sind stoffe die
fast immer auch wasser enthalten dh
diese salz rückstände müssen in
verbindung mit flüssigem wasser
entstanden sein wie genau das wasser
flüssig bleiben und die auf den bildern
soll deutlichen krater ziehen konnte
können sich die wissenschaftler noch
nicht konkret erklären erste vermutungen
klingen jedoch absolut plausibel
eine der vermutungen in wärmeren phasen
drückt sich salziges wasser an die
oberfläche und zieht den marsboden mit
sich das wasser können sich auf dem mars
nur dann im flüssigen aggregatzustand
befinden wenn es vor dem verdunsten
geschützt ist die mischung aus sand salz
und wasser wäre ein passender schutz
die andere vermutung beschäftigt sich
ebenfalls mit der verdunstung es wäre
möglich dass salz das verdunstete wasser
in der luft bindet meint die nasa
forscherin mary besseren das wasser
kondensiert also nach dem verdunsten
wieder am boden der aggregatzustand
wandelt sich also von gasförmig zu
flüssig beide vermutungen könnten die
rinnen
auf den aufnahmen erklären
rund 18 meter breite rinnen erstrecken
sich über die oberfläche des roten
planeten
flüssiges wasser habe diese gewaltigen
spuren im zuge warmer temperaturen des
sogenannten mass sommers hinterlassen
der mars durchläuft wie auch die erde
verschiedene jahreszeiten dabei treten
temperaturen von bis zu minus 130 grad
celsius bis hin zu temperaturen von über
20 grad celsius plus auf also fast wie
hier auf der erde
der zeitraum in dem wärmerer
temperaturen vorherrschen nennt man dann
mars sommer aufgrund der jedoch vermehrt
auftretenden - grase wird der planet
mars auch häufig kalte wüste genannt
diese kalte büste ist aber dennoch der
bisher erdähnlichste entdeckte planet
daher auch immer die frage nach dem
leben auf dem mars
wenn wir die arktischen zustände auf dem
mars berücksichtigen ist es ja
eigentlich kaum vorstellbar dass dort
flüssiges wasser geschweige denn leben
existieren könnte
die forscher des georgia institute of
technology sind da wie gehört jedoch
ganz anderer meinung aber wie sieht es
denn jetzt eben eigentlich aus mit dem
leben auf dem mars
wenn alle diese spuren tatsächlich von
flüssigem wasser stammen dann ist die
antwort relativ einfach wo wasser zu
finden ist ist auch so gut wie immer
leben zu finden selbst in den extremsten
situationen das sehen wir hier auf der
erde können winzige organismen überleben
und sich fortpflanzen
das heißt so unwahrscheinlich wie dieses
leben auf dem mars einst klang ist es
seit der vergangenen entdeckung nicht
mehr
jetzt beginnt die nasa jedenfalls nach
mikroorganismen zu suchen seit dieser
woche ist diese suche auf einem fremden
planeten zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der menschheit erfolg
versprechen
neben wasser wurden auch schon
spektakuläre glasablagerungen auf dem
mars gesichtet was es damit auf sich hat
erfahrt ihr im video hier oben unter dem
die einfach mit dem finger darüber
fahren oder der maus und dann drauf
klicken oder bis zum ende des videos
warten und auch zur app und zum block
kommt ihr über das sie nicht vergessen
eure meinung zum thema leben auf dem
mars ist gefragt also rein damit in die
kommentare was meint ihr
haben wir es endlich geschafft fremdes
leben im weltall zu finden
ja also diskutiert es hier unter dem
video und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran